breaking news a star-studded event at
the level Hotel in Los Angeles has been
taken over by armed gunmen we now go to
a live feed from the assailants and can
confirm that one of the hostages is
international pop star shaggy
yeah you know say he's happening
payable to me sing it shaggy honey came
in and she caught me red-handed creeping
with a girl next door
picture this we were both butt-naked
hanging out destined for how do i fork
instead I have given a extra key
[Music]
we have three waiters on the run I think
we should turn ourselves in what's with
the pockets I'm showing them I'm unarmed
we can take them my name is Alex but
three exes I'm about to go explosive on
these [ __ ] 3x means poison by
the way it's also a Vin Diesel movie
let's [ __ ] some [ __ ] up
Swatt new seals transporters
[Applause]
what are you doing up there oh thank god
the hell are you doing they're here to
help us we're not going to look cool is
[ __ ] getting saved by the LAPD do you
even listen to Kendrick Lamar love me
I give way if I follow the loser like
you around for years
guys stop you just shot at me I shot
near you [ __ ] nice ready these two
people are not married and they're going
to have premarital sex do you want to go
to heaven or do you want to go
now it is time to honor the breasts of
the women in the room I would like you
to turn to the person next to you hi is
it possible we could do a three-way I've
never done a three-way why are you in
this class you seem so together ah yeah
I really think you should come over
wouldn't have hot sex with someone who's
really nice to me let's just go have sex
in my office no I've been dating this
guy for two years I love you as his
friend and as a sexual partner won't
love why do you always call me a dirty
little [ __ ] ah just because maybe you're
you're jealous that I'm more successful
than you why are we sitting around
talking about how sad our lives are
[Music]
you're right we should be talking about
how great we are I want there to be a
lot of blood in this scene why does the
woman who enjoy sex always have to die
in horror films maybe she could fight
back I think that's probably the worst
idea ever mind her life so probably
can't do that one we talked about
pleasing men but what about pleasing us
they can I leave my laundry here get it
on Thursday you want me to do your
laundry while you date other women you
should do your laundry yeah you are so
hot like really hot
let's make a pact to be with good guys
only guys who treat us great like we
deserve well there's this guy he asked
me on a super attractive you should go
for it move over there's a new skank in
town having sex with me is a rule I just
experienced
I like your script thank you she's a
good writer I want you to do my laundry
now sex in my life
boss mere add some oil kind of turned me
on
look so why I want to have sex with you
okay no good guys only cook guys guys
only jerk sex no drift sex
let's go
medical marijuana is already a
multibillion-dollar industry the future
is this weed pill I'm still not sure
about this look most people will tell
you Buzz Aldrin walked on the moon and
even a complete idiot will tell you Neil
Armstrong did it first and do you know
why he went first because he pushed Buzz
Aldrin out of the way I'm satisfied
[Laughter]
[Music]
look man you're at some deep water
Harold like bankruptcy dude then cash
pool no I'm saying you're poor poor
tomorrow you're gonna fly to Mexico what
we want you to hand deliver the weed
pill formula to the lab yes I know I'm
not supposed to touch the minibar but
I'm going to do it you know I don't even
care anymore I'm doing it I'm having the
moon what a crybaby
Harold I'm just gonna spit this out and
hit fee we sold a little product to the
cartels but when we cut them off they
got a little angry
pretty good again not really luckily I
know a guy I've tracked down dictators
back to find a guy in middle manager is
injected the microchip I need to keep
track II can't scare me the tails of the
big bad cartels I don't things work not
in Mexico there's Harold Harold bingo
you really believe in God of course I
believe in God what kind of person does
not believe in God I guess I kind of do
but not things you can just have to get
better breathe
trust me I have good instincts tonight
we're taking game night up a notch
oh boy someone in this room is going to
be taken and it's gonna be up to you to
find them it's a murder mystery party
whoever finds the victim wins the grand
prize you're not gonna know what's real
and what's fake wait a second can't just
come in here and break the door okay
Roger dad you drive safe I've always
enjoyed the camaraderie of good friends
competing in games of chance and skill
[Music]
do I fell yeah it seems like Ryan you go
first I'm scared well
it's not a joke
people are in real danger
[Music]
oh so we take a little bath it's so much
worse
stop wait me I have kids at home not
with an ass like yet you don't oh oh no
he died his instructions on how to
remove the bullets didn't have rubbing
alcohol so I got you this lovely shot
good idea way to pivot and then a
squeaky toy for the pain good afternoon
massage as you know parole and a
privilege it's a mistake but it happened
and if I were to be released I would um
I would just want the simple life I just
want to hold down a job make some
friends you know pay my bills even if
this was possible it made twenty people
seven people why do you need to do this
cuz that's what I'm gonna how long would
it take you to make seven pieces of
jewelry in five or six hours how long if
I told you didn't have to live with your
mother anymore it's need the water flask
wait what do you need a lass
which man named ball which real name
8-ball
what if we could make all this go away
then purse as well sorry okay I mean
with my family I told him humming a
garage finally tell you how big a job
knows I'm out I take the job
I'll be back before you know can I come
with him
this is mommy's very special work trip
[Music]
in three and a half weeks the Met will
be hosting its annual ball and we are
going to Robins not the ball itself on
the neck of Daphne Kluger valued at over
a hundred million dollars revenge it's a
twofer do not run a job in a job
[Music]
user Smith can't we just go to this do
we have to steal stop yes
[Music]
is it genetic or the whole family like
this
literally
[Music]
but those mother I'm in what's going
through the laundry found these new
phones become a strip that down me
tonight I'm tearing these off with my
teeth like an old school cartoon gonna
go honey Mitch does your daughter's okay
I'm ready
you look beautiful I used to hold that
girl in the palm of my hand hey let's
becoming a woman you're gonna have to
deal with that Thanks looking for that
[Music]
why are you here you think I'm gonna
miss the most important that if you're
young hey there's my graduation
graduation is for losers tonight is the
first night of our adult lives I want to
go to prom and lose my goddamn virginity
prom night it's kind of perfect I'm in
Julie laughter that popped open you guys
are stupid on our kids all emojis have a
secret meaning Oh eggplants are dicks
this is some kind of a dick related
agreement our girls are not thinking
things through I may stop them I'm in
I'm fully planning on having sex tonight
wherever the night takes us the night's
gonna take us there wherever the wind
sails our ships your ship is going into
my harbor
[Music]
there diddly wwvv d what would Vin
Diesel do
hey fast
the Furious is completely unrealistic
it's not a documentary I get that
I'll do anything for my daughter what
about hugging contest
bring it no no right we're butt chuggin
on the count of three
they got a logger or an IPA does it
doesn't matter Oh spit roasting himself
are you a team player or aren't you I
just chugged 240 with my [ __ ] I'm a
team player why am I even trying to be a
nurse I'm gonna be delivering pizzas and
cleaning carpets for the rest of my life
you're very attractive for a carpet
cleaning lady although you maybe could
do something with your hair yeah no
that's not it it's your face
yeah give you tolling give me a little
snack you know I was just hired to do
your carpets right you're fired
I bet you haven't worked a single day in
your entire self-absorbed life just pay
me and I'll be on my way nope here's the
devil I owed the cleaning company 3000
bucks for a new machine and they fired
me rich people who get away with
everything I don't know what day it is I
don't even know my own meaning of ninja
in our little town that's him I have an
idea that is poetic and it's justice I'm
here to pick up my husband
Yuri my wife for better worse baby
yep we had to use the sperm donor you're
getting picked up for work bright and
early
I work three jobs
I want to fake husband
take them to the hospital Bobby Oh max
I'm an undercover cop working a
kidnapping case a baby panda was stolen
and they're using the dog show as a
front for animal smudger why are there
dogs in this beatty that's what partners
are for what is happening in this town
must take me Smuggler's - they're with
the world's most exclusive dog show and
Max are you in the right place I could
have swore we were backstage at a circus
so like he's on a mission you're a cop
I'm working undercover well if you
actually won the whole show nope
hey you do remember I bite right all
right coach what's our first move turn
you into this shut up
oh boy with a little bonding Reed you
waited for me to get back into that
video and some help from friends I'm
deputizing both of you yes sir I accept
but I get to be the bad cop they just
go solve the case
you are different from other show dogs
Max is a paw so as a papa from the
director of Beverly Hills Chihuahua The
Smurfs and scooby-doo a team of crime
fighter with license to buy
Felipe what are you doing who says
police work and pampering can't go Paul
and Paul dogs what's that bikini wax
it's payback time
wait the pain passes but the beauty
sheera me
seriously cut the crap guys
I'm not a rookie anymore get these off
me
rabbit it's not like we want to shave
your balls story do you want to shave
his boss me hello Foster no way you
don't want to shave his balls do you
Farva hell yeah I do
no no don't we gotta get out there
[ __ ] who ordered these I can't feel
my tits
license and registration I'm Eva - that
pulled me over before beg pardon
oh you Mounties now or should I say meow
jeez okay hang on do you really not
remember this guy you're just [ __ ]
with him I have no idea yes you know I
heard everything you said [ __ ] we've
been doing that for years
I
you see I'm so glad you're here
I'm pregnant but I don't know how to do
this by myself
your mother is the bravest person we
ever made my baby
let me tell you how she did it all on
her own
[Music]
right short the world is wide
I want to make some memories
this dress might look very pretty on you
you don't know me at all do you
[Music]
I think we should stay here together
well I wish I could stay here too turns
out he's engaged I hate it when they do
that I was cheated by you and I think
you know when look at me now will I ever
learn I don't know how but I suddenly
lose control there's a fire within my
soul I can hear about and never felt
closer to my mom she wasn't scared
because she had me
we can't tell anybody else about the
baby okay
I just told bill and I told Harry I told
many many people let's get the party
started
grandma you weren't invited that's the
best kind of party little girl pull the
trigger whose friends the nail and whack
it in one hit what you're telling me is
good by conventional hammer a life ran
out of gas you'll only ever get a little
bit of gas at a time hey you notice not
I like to come by and see you I like
seeing you as well I was hoping to save
up to taking dinner someplace nice I
love that yeah whatever you want by the
way this one's on me I've been thinking
about this ever since I first got gas at
your place you must be so excited so you
mean to tell me with no money down I can
buy it do you know what that's to Lerman
TV show we keep singing this guy this
guy's everywhere
we need to know who this man is and we
need them on this show I'm sorry about
all these cheap dates this TV I'm just a
little out of it but you do the clapper
yeah but I'm gonna bounce back
what is that your head is about to
explode that's my kid you can take that
off
all right computer somebody's making
money off and it ain't us
I subtract you like five bucks right now
just for watching that we're from the
Jamie silver-colored you recognize this
man right here yeah do you know the
clapper dirty so people came by tonight
asking all kinds of questions they'd a
photograph of you you're in trouble no
I'm not in trouble I like you Eddie I
really do wonder but I need my job like
I need my job
how'd you get this number a night every
night we want you to be honest I'm not
comfortable do you not television
anywhere it stop harassing my girl
where's Judy
[Applause]
things got out of control and I didn't
know how to handle it
the clapper it's great to finally meet
you
I mean you wanna make a big joke out of
me go ahead I just lost the only person
there matter through this whole thing I
can't tell you how nice lists good
things could come out of this
[Music]
we didn't do it again don't look at me
look at the camera you looking at me
don't look at me I know I'm talking you
but don't look at me don't look at me
look at the camera you look at me again
[Music]
nothing meant more than being in the
ring with the Panthers my wrestling
family in the nineteen eighties we
pulled in audiences of millions
now we're pulling pints and I wouldn't
change a thing
shame really that this is to be my final
point in here what's he talking about
we're going to close the aft nails it
can't be serious
yeah it's awful oh well I quit not so we
do the greatest show of our lives not
gonna be easy trying to turn the clock
back nearly 30 bleedin years little
particulars they called me the sexy
c-3po twisty Ziggy barrows what Ziggy
short [ __ ] but you short for yeah
territorial dancer
the Panthers you shall all be warriors
once more for our support so you are
viral not me may and clean as a whistle
I've seen pants you've run better than
this
I fear the man now you've got the chance
he made this a fight that won't never be
forgotten yeah this is our moment
watch them learn this rollin I don't
think they're strong land cliff oh
they're still very little they're often
often teddy Oh got me side park anywhere
else a bonus it's time to walk I love
you son hey after years of research we
discovered the male and female brain is
wired very differently to him I'm
basically a blow-up doll oh my god that
is what you look like
thank you well you know that grooming
releases endorphins in the female brain
let's not forget here's disgusting I
gave you the Brazilian straightening I
like my hair it look like those dude
from the Dukes of Hazzard
I'm eight was my American accent you
mean you don't know the Dukes of Hazzard
the area responsible for defending your
turf is larger in the male brain I'm a
physical marvel oh I'll try me throw
something I mean anything oh okay so I
wasn't ready for that women are also
more likely to recognize flaws
I threw that thing out like three years
ago I take out the trash so now it's
back laughing the fact you even want to
be MMA fighters but still wants to hold
the door open for these gender roles
they've been in us for 20,000 years look
you like this look how's it feel to be
dating magician relationships take work
want me to work two jobs why don't we
take the drug Marley is that the one to
make it eat people's faces
[Music]
she returned some music on there's no
music
[Music]
knowing your brain makes life so much
easier even though people have been
complicated nobody can deny our ability
to get back up yeah yeah you just said
yet nine times yeah can I tell you
something yeah sure I think you're a
physical marvel I see and she thought
jelly jellies not really something you
catch jellies some gravy yeah yeah you
ready
those were two peppers in a bags like
kitchen nunchucks yeah that could be a
nasty sprain why don't I get you some
ice maybe a cup of coffee what's in the
hold of it my infidelity formula you're
in fidelity for me it works ten million
people are great and as a fail-safe you
break up after six months of data
statistically speaking it's not safe to
date for longer than that what if I
could offer a way to prove your theory
wrong I don't see how you'd be able to
do that all we would need to do is find
a group of people who've been in a
relationship for longer than six months
and give them an opportunity to cheat
without getting caught what are you
proposing I'm suggesting a little
competition I pick five of my friends
who've been in a relationship for longer
than six months and you pick the
Enchantress's who will be their downfall
oh that's great
chest out well what is a competition
that's three out of five wins underwear
is pretty she wants you to go to her
place to show her how to use gym equip
you know I'm a professional didn't get
your mind out of there
you're wrong about people it's not that
simple but it is good thing this is
almost over you turn it into a regular
gangster it's not over yet
[Music]
you